[MUSIC PLAYING]
ROMAN NURIK: Hello and welcome
once again to "Android Design
in Action."
I'm your host, Roman Nurik.
NICK BUTCHER: And
hi, I'm Nick Butcher.
MIKE DENNY: Hey there.
I'm Mike Denny.
ROMAN NURIK: And
today we're going
to recap all the
things that we talked
about on the show in 2013.
It's been a busy year.
We've had something like
20 or something episodes
just this yea-- actually
probably more than 20.
NICK BUTCHER: This is
the 23rd this year.
ROMAN NURIK: 23rd this year.
Nice.
We've had a busy
year, and we're going
to talk about all the different
kind of highlights of the show
this year.
NICK BUTCHER: So I'm sure that
you guys have watched them all,
but just in case, we're going to
pull out some of the highlights
that we very much enjoyed
bringing to you over the year.
ROMAN NURIK: All right.
So without further
ado, let's get started.
So in 2013, we had about
600,000 total views
of all of our episodes.
About a third of that came
from our episode on KitKat--
actually about half,
which is great.
But this is awesome.
I'm personally
really, really happy
that you guys are
finding the show useful,
that you're sharing
it with your product
managers, and your
designers, and developers,
and hopefully in 2014, we
have even greater viewership.
So thanks for watching.
So with that little bit
out of the way, Mike,
do you want to jump in
with some of our episodes
on shared inspiration and
maybe some of our rants?
MIKE DENNY: Yeah, definitely.
So we were looking back
on all these episodes
from this past year, and
we want to kind of group
them in general themes.
And so I'm going to
be talking about a lot
of the different
inspirational segments
that we had on the show
and also some of our rants,
where we just kind of go off
about how we think things
should be, and how
people can improve,
and how we can help them.
So to start with that, I'm
going to look at the episode
that we did about
design workflow.
Actually we had Alex Faaborg
from the Android Design team
on the show.
And he walked us through some
of just the general structure
that the Android Design
team here at Google
uses in their design process.
And this can
definitely be helpful
if you're looking for a little
more structure and process
to help you improve in
your design practices.
As we can see here from
these little slide frames,
the first couple steps
are about sketches.
And sketching is great
because it gives you a chance
to get your ideas
out onto the paper
that you can then share
with other stakeholders
without committing to anything.
So paper is great, but if
you don't have access--
or if you prefer to do
something on computer,
there are definitely a lot
of sketching tools available
online that you
can go check out.
For any of these episodes
that we're doing,
feel free to go back and
watch the whole episode.
These are definitely recaps.
So I just wanted
to point that out.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah,
and the other thing
is that we have slides
and-- not really commentary,
I guess-- we mostly
have slides available
for each of the episodes.
So don't feel like you
need to take screenshots,
or whatever, of this show.
We have all the slides
and all the videos
available at
androiddesigninaction.com.
We'll mention that link
at the very end as well.
MIKE DENNY: Yep.
Yep.
Just wanted to get
that out there.
So after sketching,
after getting
some feedback from
your coworkers
or whoever you're
working with, it's
great to generate
additional ideas as well.
And then you can
move on to f which
is a little bit more
formalized process
where-- especially for modeling
interactions between screens
and user flows-- more on flows
as we see it in step five
there.
After you block out the
main interactions and U/I
layouts with f it's a
good next natural step
to move on to the more high
fidelity or full fidelity
mockups in Photoshop
or Illustrator,
whatever your asset
generation tool of choice is.
And this is definitely
an iterative process.
If you go back and look at the
full slides, there are about 10
of these full fidelity
mockup slides that
have all the different
iterations of the little header
image or the Google Mail app
that the design team went
through during that process.
You also want to go back and
make sure that you can clearly
distinguish and spell out the
overall flow through your app.
And it helps to
visualize that, maybe,
using an art board
in Illustrator
with all the
multiple screens, so
that you can kind of visually
show the mental model
of your information
design in your app.
And then redlines
are-- it's just
a term to describe
the specific metrics
and spec for the developers who
are going to be implementing
the designs that you've created.
So that's always
helpful to give them
just a bunch of assets in
addition to specific metrics
to spell out.
You know, this list item
should be 48 DIPs tall,
this padding around should
be 16 DIPs, et cetera.
So the next episode that
I want to recap is--
NICK BUTCHER: Before
we move on, I just
want to say my overriding memory
of this kind of design process,
takeaway, was Alex
sharing the insight
that often the medium you
use to express your ideas
will dictate the kind of
feedback you get back.
So if you show someone a very
highly designed, Photoshop,
pixel-perfect, then you're
going to get comments
about the shade of blue
and drop shadow size.
Whereas if you show
someone a sketch,
they'll go to town
on the basic idea.
And I thought that was
a really important thing
to be cognizant of
when you're designing,
to keep the fidelity
of the medium in mind.
So it kind of just
reinforced to me,
always be sketching, keep
sketching as early as possible,
and get loads and
loads of base feedback
before you move it on
into some of these more
high fidelity [INAUDIBLE].
MIKE DENNY: Yeah, definitely.
Thanks for pointing
that out, Nick.
And it's great.
I mean obviously I
recently joined the team.
I wasn't in almost
all of these episodes,
so Roman and Nick, please
feel free to jump in
as I'm recapping these with--
NICK BUTCHER: Oh, we will.
MIKE DENNY: I'm sure you will.
One more thing
that Alex mentioned
as kind of a social
engineering hack for anytime
you present your
designs is to show
them using the tool
you use to create them.
So if your manager starts going
off on a tangent-- you know,
I wish that was just a little
bit bigger-- you could just
go change it right then.
And he can decide
if it were bigger
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
ROMAN NURIK: So rather
than showing a PDF,
basically show them in
Illustrator or in Photoshop.
Yep.
MIKE DENNY: Yeah.
Definitely.
So moving on, the next
episode I'm going to recap
is the one in which we
presented the apps that
were selected to be part of
the Beautiful Design Collection
that we featured in Google Play.
This is a fairly
regular process that we
do here and on the team.
And it's definitely
worth going back
to check out those
apps to understand
why we really, really love them.
And it's one of the
great things that I
think is worth mentioning here
is that these aren't apps that
were 100% Holo, cookie
cutter, kind of-- you could,
you confuse them with
Google standard apps that
come with the platform.
These were apps that understand
the Holo design language,
but then extend and go
beyond to add real hero
moments in their
app and to express
their brand in a
more meaningful way.
ROMAN NURIK: In this episode
really kind of highlighted
some of those things.
One or two of the little
details in each app that really
made it shine, that really
made it stand kind of above,
I guess, the
competition, if you will.
MIKE DENNY: Yeah, and
along the same lines,
the next episode that we
looked at was in June.
And we did a bit of a
recap on the creation
and the design of
the Google I/O app,
which is actually a really great
open-source project that we
update every year in
anti-- ahead of Google I/O.
And we like throwing in latest
developments and new features
in the platform.
And it's definitely
a great reference app
to go back and look at how
a developer can implement
the kinds of design
principles as we
talk about on "Android
Design in Action."
ROMAN NURIK: Yep.
And it supports all
the best practices,
things like support for
different screen sizes,
use of heavy-- very, very
heavy use of fragments,
and loaders, and
things like that.
But also shows a lot about how
to style your action bar, how
to do interesting things
with the action bar.
So lots of good little
tidbits in that app.
MIKE DENNY: Yep.
Yep.
Definitely.
So definitely go back
and check that out.
And also check out the
open-source project
or the Google I/O app.
ROMAN NURIK: And that's at
code.google.com/p/iosched.
I remember that like
the back of my hand.
MIKE DENNY: If only we could
just show a link on the screen
that you could click.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, we could
probably do that in post.
MIKE DENNY: In addition, if
you look at the high definition
video on YouTube here,
if you scan the QR
code at the bottom
of the slide there,
it'll take you to the Play Store
where you can download and play
with the app.
ROMAN NURIK: Yep.
Moving on?
MIKE DENNY: Yeah.
So this was a great
episode in which
Marco and Owen from
the Android Design team
came on and talked about
the sweeping redesign--
multi-platform redesign
of the Google Play apps.
So that includes the
Play Store itself
and all the different
media apps that you
can use to consume content
that you have on Google Play--
movies, music, books, et cetera.
So all those apps
were redesigned
from the ground up with kind
of the overarching principles
that they were going
for to be responsive,
to have modular
elements, and also
to be familiar and emotionally
evocative throughout.
So before-- if you
go back and look
at the episode they show some
before here I'm only showing
the after and kind
of the nice look
and feel you guys are used
to now-- but if you go back
and look before,
they showed kind
of the design fragmentation
between the web product,
between the tablet
and phone products.
And so it was
definitely a great move
to bring everything
together, to brand everything
in a way that it sets an example
for apps outside of Google,
especially with
the use of color--
and we'll talk about that more
when we discussed the branding
and consistency.
It's just a great example
of responsive apps
where the U/I adapts
to the screen size.
And the U/I is very
fluid and dynamic
based on the device
you are using.
And it also caters to common
use cases on those devices.
For example, if I use my
phone to download an app,
that might be a totally
different experience
than browsing for a movie
to watch on my tablet.
So the apps were redesigned
with that in mind, especially.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, and
some of the key things
that they use-- they
describe their use of cards
as kind of this inside
out design approach
where the content really
adapts to its containers.
And they talked lot
about use of-- I
guess the differentiation
of these cards,
of sizes and things, to better
enforce hierarchy and what's
most important, what's
most relevant to you.
I mean obviously, Mike, as
you said, the use of color
is tremendous here across
all the Play properties.
It really helps kind of
establish a sense of place
within the entire
Play ecosystem.
So red if you're in movies, or
blue if you're within books.
MIKE DENNY: Yeah,
yeah, definitely.
So you always know
where you are.
And one thing I wanted
to point out about cards
is I think this is probably the
most sweeping implementation
of the cards U/I that
we've seen thus far.
I think it started
initially with Google Now.
And now you can see this
kind of card metaphor
throughout almost
every Google product.
That doesn't mean
necessarily that you
have to put cards in your app.
You shouldn't try to force it.
I know it's kind
of become somewhat
of a visual design trend.
Just understanding the
purpose of the card
to kind of encapsulate a single
idea or a piece of content
is a way to use that card
metaphor in your designs
responsibly.
ROMAN NURIK: So let's move on.
And yeah, definitely feel free
to check out that episode.
There's a lot of good content
specifically about cards.
Marco and Owen talk
about why they use them.
Let's move on to
Favorite Design Details.
Actually one thing I
wanted to point out
is one of the properties that
launched after that episode was
Google Play Newsstand, or the
purple section of Google Play.
And that's actually--
Marco actually
discusses that in this Favorite
Design Details episode.
So that's Marco
up here, this guy.
Check out his segment
of this episode
for a discussion of
Google Play Newsstand.
MIKE DENNY: Yeah, yeah.
So Rachel Garb on the
top row there, she
talked about the Airbnb app.
Roman, you talked
about Foursquare.
Nick talked about Google
Chrome and new kind
of non-obvious
interaction patterns
that are kind of like
power user features.
Rich Fulcher from the design
team talked about Libra app.
And the Libra app is fantastic
in it's visualization
of data, how they've
really made it interactive.
So they track the weight,
you zoom in, zoom out,
and you can kind of
scale using gestures.
It's a great experience.
I talked about the
Timely app which
is a stopwatch, alarm
clock, et cetera.
And Nick talked
about-- or sorry--
ROMAN NURIK: Adam.
MIKE DENNY: Adam talked
about the Etsy app.
ROMAN NURIK: Actually, sorry.
Quick tidbit there.
When Adam and Nick
first joined the team--
or I think when Adam
joined the team,
I always confused Adam and Nick.
You know why?
Because they're
both taller than me.
[LAUGHTER]
ROMAN NURIK: But
yeah, Mike, go on.
I didn't mean to
interrupt you there so.
MIKE DENNY: And Adam
recorded his bit
from New York, which is why
his little background there
looks a little bit different.
But one thing I
wanted to point out
is that only a couple of
these were Google apps.
And for the third-party
apps that we talked about,
notice that they weren't
pure Google apps.
However, they were
pure Android apps.
So with brand
consistency, this is
going to be a theme in
some of the other things I
talk about today.
You want to
communicate your brand,
and you want to also
stay pure to Android.
So pure Android
doesn't necessarily
mean you can't deviate
from the design principles.
Like we encourage to
deviate with purpose.
And so the general overall
theme of this episode
was that if you put the
extra effort in-- which
a lot of times takes
quite a bit more than just
the regular features--
to add hero moments,
to add just slick animations,
beautiful visual presentation,
and really easy to understand
and use interaction patterns,
it'll just make a huge
difference overall.
ROMAN NURIK: Shall we move on
to Branding and Consistency?
MIKE DENNY: Yep.
So I've talked about this
a couple times already.
I just wanted to
illustrate this graph.
I don't know who--
ore this presentation,
I don't know if this was--
ROMAN NURIK: I think it was
Nick that talked a little.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, that was me.
I was trying to think
of a way to express it,
and I got the most number of
gradients on a slide ever,
I think.
MIKE DENNY: Well when
I watched this episode,
I felt like you
expressed this kind
of complex and touchy subject
in the most clear-to-understand
way that I've heard
it expressed to date.
So kudos, Nick.
So the idea of this
is your information
design, your interaction
design, and your visual design,
should kind of have a different
balance between your own brand
and the Holo or Android visual
style and design language.
So the information
design, the architecture
of your app, how information
flows throughout your app,
and also how a user
understands the interactions,
the mental model-- those
are very, very brandable.
And you should express
your information design
as creatively as
you can and really
let your simplicity and
your branding shine there.
On the other hand,
interaction design--
you don't want to introduce
new interaction patterns
for simple navigation or high
level switching between views.
Because extra stuff that
the platform already
does for you for
free is just going
to confuse users or add steps
for them to learn how to use
your app, when you
should really just
be finding the right fit
for existing patterns
and, where needed,
extending those.
So it's not necessarily that all
the components that we provide
in the platform are the only
things you should use, right?
But if you need a little
extra flexibility,
you should at least use
one of the base components
as a starting point.
And then for visual
design, which
is what most people
associate with branding,
you want to strike a balance.
So they pointed
out in the episode
that the best way, probably,
to use your branding,
to highlight your branding
in your visual design is
through the use of
a branded color.
A fantastic example of this
is throughout the Play apps
where each Play property
has its own color.
And that helps
between multiple apps
to keep you kind of in context
of which property you're
dealing with at the time.
Now for most people
out there, they're
not going to be developing a
suite of apps like the Play
Store.
But at the same time, you
don't want your user interface
to be your brand.
The navigation is not the brand.
The way this button looks
can kind of be your brand.
So that's where this slider is
kind of halfway in the middle.
You want to take the core look
and feel of the Holo design
language and then extend that.
Don't, you know, replace
the right angle triangle
in the spinner drop down
with something else.
You know, start with
that familiar place,
and then you can kind of
use those expected metaphors
and visual indicators
throughout,
so that users know exactly how
a component-- even if it isn't
exactly as it
looks, they'll know
how it can be used
because you're
kind of starting
at the right place.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah,
that's a great summary.
Basically if you're
going to make something,
you should make your U/I
elements interesting.
You give them some
extra, you know,
bit of-- put in that
extra punch of branding.
But make sure they're
still very, very familiar
because you really want to
lean on what you already know.
And what users already
know are the things
that are in apps like Gmail,
and Google Keep, and Chrome.
Things like the overflow,
things like tabs
and the navigation
drawer, those things
exist in terms of
interaction design.
For visual design
you really want
to take that and
kind of extend Holo.
Not replace it, not
use it wholesale.
But really extend it, and
really kind of pump it
with your own sense, with
your own branding I guess.
MIKE DENNY: Yeah definitely.
And the design principle
from the Android Design Guide
that really is expressed here
is that users should have tricks
that they can use everywhere.
And so that's what we've
been talking about.
These little visual
indicators that users
expect to behave in a certain
way, don't go replacing that
just because you
think it looks cool.
ROMAN NURIK: OK so let's
move on to Common UX Issues.
MIKE DENNY: Yes.
So this was definitely one of
our more ranty episodes where--
ROMAN NURIK: There's
one long rant.
[LAUGHTER]
MIKE DENNY: There's a top
10 list, we counted it back,
of really common UX
issues or problems
that we on the Developer
Relations team see.
So part of our everyday job is
to review apps internally here
at Google and also outside.
We work with a lot of you guys
to help you improve your apps.
And these are just things
that we've seen over,
and over, and over.
And we felt like going on a
rant and spelling them out
would hopefully prevent them
from spreading to more apps
out there in the wild.
So I pulled out just
a couple of these.
For the full list and
the full detail rant,
definitely check
out the episode so
that you know what not to do.
But things that I
wanted to point out
were-- like the
navigation is my brand,
like I mentioned for
the previous episode.
Additional things that
can be pretty annoying
are showing modal
loading dialogs.
The best way to
deal with loading
in data asynchronously
over the network
is to do it before you
show it to the user.
So wherever possible,
obviously that's
not possible in every
case, especially
for real-time
updates-- if the user
wants to update a social
feed, for example.
But when presenting
a loading indicator,
it's best to do it in
line, either with the U/I
element that's currently loading
or somewhere more prominent
on the action bar, for example,
to indicate that something's
loading in from the network,
but not necessarily a popup
dialog that blocks
off your action.
The worst thing about this
is when you override the Back
button so that you can't cancel
the dialog until the loading
process actually completes.
So that's a big no-no.
And definitely should
go through your apps
and kind of streamline
your use of loading.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah,
this was a fun top 10.
So if you're
working on an app, I
recommend you go back
and look at these top 10
and make sure you're not
falling foul of them.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
Let's move on in the
interest of the time.
So I'm going to flip through
a bunch of best practices.
And actually-- so those
episodes are very inspirational.
We had a bunch of rants.
A lot of that is kind of on
the-- less on the education
side, I guess.
Less on the learning about
Android and more about like,
here are the types of things
you should be thinking about.
In this best practices section,
I'm going to talk about some
of the episodes, and very
briefly, some of the episodes
where we actually shared
some best practices,
some of our-- kind of the
specifics on how you implement
action bars or how you
implement navigation charts,
or things like that.
So the first one I want to
talk about is Units of Measure.
In this episode, which was
actually coupled with news
Reader redesign, which
Nick will talk about later.
We talked specifically about
density independent pixels,
how you calculate DIPs, screen
density grids, basically
everything related to a lot of
the visual design and layout
stuff that you need to know.
It's kind of like a visual
design 101 for Android,
if you will.
So if you're just
getting started,
definitely check
out this episode
where we talk about
units of measure.
We also talked about
looking at devices
in terms of their density
independent pixel resolution
rather than their
pixel resolution.
So for example,
the Nexus 7 being
960 by 600 DIPs and the Nexus
5 being 640 by 360 DIPs.
And that's a really,
really important point
if you're getting started
doing layout for Android.
Moving on, we had
another great episode
on the onboarding experience.
And Nick actually came up
with this little-- the idea
of using a little snowboarder
as the icon for this episode.
NICK BUTCHER: Great.
There you've got
it, [INAUDIBLE].
ROMAN NURIK: No, I got it.
I think we all got it.
I think nobody talked
about it, but we got it.
This episode specifically
talked about a bunch
of the different ways in which
you can mess up-- and not
only mess up but also improve
the getting started experience
for your app.
So things like
speed bump tutorials
and basically avoiding those,
requiring registration,
splash screens,
basically getting
bootstrapped with the app.
We talked about lots
of things there.
One of my favorite things that
we did is we talked about some
of the examples.
One of my favorite apps
in this space is Tumblr.
It actually lets you do
so much without signing
in, or registering, or anything.
You open up the app,
and you're immediately
given the full app, the full
U/I, the full experience.
You can even start following
blogs or following Tumblr blogs
before you log in.
So it's just a great
example of that.
And then we also briefly talked
about over-the-air install with
the Google+ integration stuff.
So--
NICK BUTCHER: In
this one episode too,
it's one of my bugbear
kind of subjects.
I kind of like to
think that there's
a funnel of people
trying to use your app,
and every time you do one of
these kind of antipatterns,
the funnel gets smaller
and you lose a few users.
So it's really kind of like
an interesting exercise
to critically look
at your startup flow
and see where you
are potentially
going to lose some people.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, for sure.
The next best practice
thing we talked about, again
in the area of visual
design, was launcher icons.
And this episode was coupled
with a football apps--
or soccer apps as we
say here in the States.
Soccer or football
apps redesign.
So in this episode, we talked
about some best practices
for designing launcher
icons-- the sizes,
the amount of spacing
you should use,
also the perspective
and specifically the
density of assets.
So there's one thing that
still keeps coming up.
Don't forget to include XXHDPI
assets for launcher icons.
And in the new world of Nexus 5
and larger icons on the Nexus 5
launcher, it should
actually be also XXXHDPI.
So definitely make sure
to check out this episode
if you're designing
launcher icons.
Moving on, we did another
episode basically doing
a 101 on the action bar.
I'm guessing if you've
been watching this show--
or if this is your first
episode, thanks for watching.
But if you have learned
anything about Android so far,
it's probably-- or
Android design so far,
you've probably learned a
little bit about the action bar.
In this episode, we dove
into quite a bit of detail
on the action bar-- the
general organization, you know,
which things should go where,
navigation on the left,
actions on the right.
We talked about some
guidelines for how many actions
you should show.
And we also talked
about branding,
and this is kind of
that recurring theme
that Mike was talking
about earlier.
Here's some of the
ways in which you
can start introducing your
branding into the app.
And the action bar is
a key area for that,
so we highlighted
some ways in which
you can introduce your
brand color schemes.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah
the action bar
is one of those
fundamental patterns
that we say you should
probably deviate with purpose.
So unless you've got really
good reason not to be using it,
you probably should be using it.
So if you're not 100% sure
about how and when to use it,
then check out this episode.
ROMAN NURIK: Yep.
So after the action bar,
we invited Jens Nagle
and Rich Fulcher from
the Android Design team.
And we talked
about Rich earlier.
He was talking
about the Libra app
in our Favorite Design
Details episode.
But Jens and Rich,
back in June, they
talked about the
navigation drawer.
And this was right
after Google I/O, where
we announced the
navigation drawer
pattern and a bunch of the
framework support for it.
But in this episode,
Jens and Rich
dove very deeply into
the interaction design
aspects of the
navigation drawer.
So things like what
should the Back button do?
How should you represent
your information hierarchy
in the navigation drawer?
They talked about things
like collapsible sections.
I guess they talked about
hubs, navigational hubs, that
are kind of like deeper
sections of your app
that should still be
accessible within the drawer.
So they talked about a whole
bunch of details there.
That's actually some
pretty good information
on top of what's in
the design guide.
So if you're building
a navigation drawer,
definitely check
out this episode.
MIKE DENNY: So the next episode
we did was on collections.
And specifically, we
showed some I guess--
we talked about some best
practices by way of examples
on how lots of apps right now
are doing things right in terms
of displaying, letting
you search and filter,
and so on collections,
as well as
mutate-- things like adding
items to a collection,
removing items from a
collection, reordering,
taking action on items,
things like that.
So we talked about some things
like distillation, things
like search and filter, having
a right side filter drawer.
We talked about
responsive layout,
basically switching from lists
to a grid to a staggered grid,
like here an example of Pocket.
We talked about
how different apps
let you act on
items using things
like the contextual
action bar, as well
as secondary actions
and item overflows.
Reordering items like using
a drag group on the side,
or Google Keep which is
actually an excellent example
of collections-- displaying
and modifying collections,
but notes in this case
how they actually use drag
and drop to let you reorder.
So this episode
really, in summary,
is really just kind of
a smorgasbord almost
of different ways
in which apps are
doing things great in
terms of collections.
OK, moving on.
The next the best practice
episode type thing that we had
was one on images that
we did back in October.
And here we talked
about the different ways
in which you can actually do
interesting things with images.
So we talked about some best
practices like how to show text
overlays when showing
banner images or thumbnails.
We talked about placeholders
in this example.
We talked about
how Pintrest does
a great job of actually keying
the placeholder a color,
based on the image.
So they actually-- it seems like
they store another bit almost
in the database of the
key color in the image,
and they show that color
before the image itself loads.
So gives you a little
touch of context
as to what's going to
show up in that space.
We also talked about the
center cropping technique,
which is a great way to
basically allow your U/Is
to scale to different
aspect ratios.
And in the center cropping
technique you basically--
it's actually very
simple to use.
You actually just set the
scale type to center crop
on an image view.
But in this technique,
you basically
chop off either
the left and right
or the top and
bottom of an image
if the aspect ratio of the
image and its target destination
don't match.
And we also talked
about focus, things
like using blurring
and dimming techniques
to help the user really focus
on the most important things,
whether it be the text in
front, or gray scaling an image
if it's not important,
and things like that.
So overall we just
touched on a bunch
of different best practices
and a couple of ideas
on how to present images.
So moving on, we did another
episode on best practices
for presenting Maps in your app.
So we talked about things like
the different ways in which
users can interact, or should
be able to interact with a map.
The different ways in which
you can present and allow
interaction with
markers in info windows.
And we spent some time talking
about the visual design
of markers, basically
how you can introduce
branding into something that
is from a shape standpoint.
The shape of a marker
is generally pretty
standard, but how
you can actually
introduce some of your branding
into that as well as how
to deal with density.
If you have tons
and tons of markers,
how can you actually
still allow the users
to see the map underneath
all the markers?
So we talked about
that for quite a bit.
We talked about full screen,
and I'll get to that and second.
We talked about an
embedded map mode
which Foursquare does
really well with.
But we talked a bit
about full screen,
and actually in
Android 4.4, we also
talked about translucent
navigation and status bars.
And these actually
go hand in hand.
Another thing that we talked
about in the Android 4.4
episode was map padding.
So actually in recent
versions of the map library,
you can offset these controls
like the zoom control, as well
as the compass, and
my location control.
You can actually
offset those and still
show the map above and
below those controls.
So it really helps
when presenting a map
in this kind of more full
screen or more immersive mode.
Before we move on, I've
been talking a lot.
You guys have any comments on
maps or anything like that?
NICK BUTCHER: Nope.
You're doing a great job.
ROMAN NURIK: All right,
let's plow ahead.
We did another episode
on home screen widgets.
This is back in March.
And in this episode, we talked
about the different types
of home screen widgets, things
like information only widgets
like your current weather, or a
control widgets like the power
control, hybrid widgets
and collection widgets.
We talked about the different
kind of patterns for content
to show inside of a widget.
We also, not pictured in
these thumbnails here,
we talked about some
of the constraints,
like things you just
can't do with widgets.
Like you can't play videos
in widgets unfortunately.
But we did talk about some
of the things you can do.
Like you can actually allow
for configuration of a widget.
So one of the great
things about widgets
is that they let a user
take a bit of your app
and put it on their home screen,
one of the most valuable pieces
of real estate on their device.
And one of the best ways
to have a successful widget
is to allow customization,
really let the user make it
their own.
We also talked about some
best practices for sizing.
Basically when you're designing
the layout for a widget,
we talked about
some formulas you
can use to roughly figure
out how big it should be.
NICK BUTCHER: I think one of
the most important things we
touched on there which perhaps
isn't quite as well-documented
as I'd like in our
design guidelines,
is the fact that you're
sharing some real estate.
So while your app has the
full range of expression
of its brand, and
so forth, when it's
taking over the whole screen,
when you are creating a widget,
you have to bear in
mind the context that it
will be presented next to other
widgets or other app icons.
So I think that was a
really important section
in that episode.
It's how you design your
widget so that it will go along
with those other and
home screen items.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
Specifically the visual
design of the widgets.
It is more important to
be on that slider branding
consistency, more
important than in your app
to be closer to the Android
and Holo end of that spectrum
when you're designing a widget
because it's next to everything
else.
NICK BUTCHER: Yep.
But we love widgets.
It can make an app
stand out and really
differentiate your
app from the crowd.
ROMAN NURIK: All
right, moving on.
We did a little
bit in this section
where we talked
about the I/O app.
In the episode where we
talked about the I/O app,
we also talked about
sharing in fullscreen U/Is.
So sharing, I'm not going to
get into too much depth here.
But we talked about
the different ways
in which you can allow
users to share content.
Things like the shared
dialog that's very standard.
Things like the share action
provider in the action bar.
The idea here is--
the big message
here is that you should
really allow sharing
to anything that's
on the user's device,
not just specifically to
two social networks or one
social network.
You should really
kind of use whatever
the system has installed.
So keep that in mind when
designing sharing U/Is.
In the fullscreen,
I guess, area, we
talked about system bars,
things like the status bar
and the navigation bar.
And then we talked a whole bunch
about different interesting
ways in which you
can use those bars,
having an overlay action
bar, or dimming out
the status bar and
navigation bar.
Lots of different interactions
you can create here.
And these were-- we
talked about them
in even more depth
in a later episode.
I think it was the
KitKat episode.
When we introduced
immersive mode in KitKat,
we talked about some
of the even newer ways
you can do really,
really fullscreen, really
immersive U/Is.
So if you're building a
fullscreen experience,
like a video player,
or a fullscreen game,
or a book reader, or
even a photo gallery,
definitely make sure to check
out this episode from June 4th
as well as the KitKat episode
which was very recent.
All right, moving on.
I think we're at the end-- yeah
this is my last slide here.
The last kind of best practice
and best practice type
episode we had was
about design tools.
So in this episode, we talked
a lot about the different tools
that the designers
on the Android team
use-- things like obviously
Illustrator, Fireworks,
Photoshop.
But we also talked about
some of the interaction--
I guess some of the
wireframing tools
that you have available to
you as an Android designer--
things like OmniGraffle
or Fluid UI, or Proto.io.
We did a compare and contrast
of those different interaction
design tools.
And there are probably countless
more today than there were back
when we did this
episode, but if you're
looking for a
getting started guide
on which tools you
should get started with,
definitely this
is a good episode.
One last thing is we briefly
talked about the Android Design
Preview tool which lets
you mirror something
from your computer, from
like a Photoshop window,
to your device.
You can see it live.
And we talked about things
like the Android Asset
Studio, and Holo Colors
Generator, and Action Bar Style
Generator, that
let you basically
create all the assets you need
for the basics of your Android
app.
Things like the action
bar background and things
like that.
NICK BUTCHER: Tooling is
always an emotive subject.
I mean people feel
passionate about their tools.
And it's interesting,
some the feedback
we got from that episode.
And some new tools have emerged.
I think, for me, Sketch
is one of the tools which
is on my list of
tools to check out.
A lot of people
are saying they're
having a lot of
success using that
for kind of a
effective base design.
ROMAN NURIK: For sure.
OK.
And I think that about covers it
for the best practices section.
Nick do you want to talk
about all the redesigns
and mockups we did in 2013?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, absolutely.
So redesigns are kind
of very much in the DNA
of the "Android Design
in Action" show.
It's kind of the "in
action" part where
we like to show rather than
just talk about things.
And so while they
take a lot of time,
and we haven't been
able to do quite as many
as perhaps we'd like,
there's been some really,
really fun shows
where we've managed
to either reimagine certain
apps out there or take
a look at a hypothetical app,
of what it might look like.
And so we're going to
take you through some
of our favorite redesigns.
So all the way back in January,
the first meat-flavored--
your favorite meat flavored
reader app-- the first time
we introduced it.
This was an episode
where we introduced
this idea of iterative design.
So it was really, really fun
to take an application which
you had like zero styling
applied to it at all.
It just had some real
content in there.
And walk you through
the steps that we
would do to improve things like
applying themes, and applying
the metrics in the
Android Design Guide,
and take a look at typography,
and literally build it up step
by step.
And as you can see as
Roman pans around here,
to go from something which
looks completely bare,
you know doesn't look
like an Android app.
You're not exactly
sure how to use it, to,
you know, something which
looks really attractive
and communicates this
information hierarchy,
and really sells the content.
So if you haven't
checked this out,
this is probably one of my
all-time favorite episodes
of "Android Design in Action."
Really, really
again, it breaks down
how we go about improving
your application.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, the one
thing we tried to do throughout
is talk about some of
the developer features
that we used.
So on the bottom right
of a lot of the slides
there's a little kind of
"for developers" notes.
So keep that in mind
if you're a developer.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, absolutely.
Next episode I want to
talk about is in February,
we took a look at football--
not soccer-- football apps,
in particular the application
Live Score Addicts.
And we reimagined
what it could look
like by applying some more of
the Android Design guidelines.
So we did a lot of
things we normally
do like kind of applying a
more Androidy kind of flatter
looking view, and
using action bars,
and so forth, which
I think, instantly it
made it look more like
an Android app to me.
It made it communicate its
purpose, its interaction
patterns, much clearer
to me after the redesign.
So I was a fan of that.
But the two things I wanted
to mostly pull out here,
and they're kind of
slightly larger pictures.
I really enjoyed
with this redesign
taking a look at the
navigation, the way
the major navigation
is organized.
Because they were previously
using a drawer which
seemed to-- there wasn't
too many major sections
to this application.
So by kind of flattening
down their kind of navigation
hierarchy, we were
able to move it over
to using a tab based interface
with lesser used functions
tucked away under the
overflow, like settings.
And that instantly
was much clearer.
I think if you can use a tab
based navigation where in which
it immediately communicates
the apps purpose to the user.
Or using here-- using the action
bar spinner, sorry, not tabs.
Then I thought this was a
great stepping back exercise,
and not using a drawer
just because it's
attractive or a new [INAUDIBLE],
but actually thinking
of the simplest way to
communicate these actions.
That was really fun.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, one of my
favorite parts of this, we
also did a bit with
the color scheme.
We talk a lot about
single accent colors.
Like a lot of the
Play properties
use a single accent color.
In this case, we
actually in the redesign
we decided to use two accent
colors-- this, I guess,
desaturated dark brown and
almost like a forest green.
So don't feel like you should be
limited to single accent color.
If it makes sense for your
app to use two accent colors,
absolutely feel free to do that.
Here's just one example
of how we did that.
NICK BUTCHER: Yes,
that was quick.
Moving on.
So in March, we look
at how you might
create a hypothetical
news reader.
So we built on top
of this, kind of,
XYZ this kind of meaty
reader, and explored
some interesting
ways in which you
can do news reading experiences.
So there was some fun stuff
about explorations in there.
Things like using
multi-finger gestures in order
to kind of peek more
content, leading
to a kind of a lighter
weight process and so forth.
I was really interested
in the use of search
to flatten the hierarchy.
I thought that was
really interesting.
A lot of applications struggle
with how you communicate
a really, really complicated
hierarchy of topics
and so forth.
And using search
and customization
to flatten and
navigate that I thought
was a fun approach to it.
That was very good.
ROMAN NURIK: One brief
thing I want to mention
is this mock up was done before
we had the official navigation
drawer pattern, so some of the
mock ups, some of the designs
you see here are actually
not quite up to date
in terms of how you should
use the navigation drawer.
NICK BUTCHER: Oh yeah.
Bulldozing content.
What's that all about?
But lastly, I think that
the kind of the bottom right
image, it's the
slide [INAUDIBLE].
I very much enjoyed
the discussion
we had around focusing
on content because kind
of these news reader apps,
it's all about content.
It's all about presenting
and getting users to a story
they want to read.
And the little
interface design things
that you can do to make that
reading experience, the reason
they're there, more
pleasant can really help.
So we played some ideas
around hiding the action bar,
about when to
surface new content,
about going into this
kind of lights out mode,
as we call it, where you dim any
other distractions in the U/I.
I thought that was
really fun to really,
really have a
laser-focused application.
And so that was good.
ROMAN NURIK: Moving on.
NICK BUTCHER: Next up
was an episode in March
where we took a look at
what a hypothetical podcast
creator might look like.
So this was an app where
we had kind of mocked it
up and designed.
But stepping back
from that, I really
enjoyed that we
started from the stage
before the mock ups and
redesigns, if you will.
We started from the
information hierarchy
and really took
some time to think
about what it was this
app was trying to achieve
and how that would influence
the screen design later on.
So I really enjoyed that we
kept the information model.
And in fact, we used the
labels throughout the design
to show which screens were
ticking off certain use
cases we were
trying to cover off.
So that was a fun episode.
Which I don't think
I was there for.
But I did enjoy watching it.
ROMAN NURIK: Moving on.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, moving on.
In July, we took a look at the
application called FINN.no.
ROMAN NURIK: This is actually
from GDG Oslo, I believe.
We did kind of a
live app clinic,
I guess, with the
creators of this app.
And then they were like, hey,
can you show us some ideas--
or show some mock ups of
how you would design this.
So we went ahead and did that.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah
that was a fun one.
So I think there was some
really nice work done
to better express the kind
of information hierarchy.
So in general,
reorganization there.
As well as moving some
of the interface patterns
like the action bar and
the navigation drawer a bit
closer to the platform pattern
in order to kind of make
them feel more intuitive so that
users going to kind of pick up
the application and know
how to navigate around,
which I thought was really nice.
But the one thing I wanted to
highlight in this application,
we touched on it-- couple of
seconds ago, couple of minutes
ago, talking about
information collections--
was the use of the right side
drawer for sorting options.
I very much enjoyed this.
This is a great way to
bundle up your options.
And it can feel like a
lighter weight action
rather than taking you
off to a second screen
or dialog perhaps.
So letting them, kind of,
set their sorting options.
And better yet, if
you can have them,
say, updating the background.
So I can see as I move that
slide to left or right,
if I can see the
number of results
changing in the background.
I think its really,
really nice way
to make it feel like I'm
directly working on this data,
rather than it's this slow
machinery process there
and pulling a lever and
that's causing a process
to go somewhere else.
I thought that was a
really, really nice touch
in that episode.
ROMAN NURIK: Moving on.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
ROMAN NURIK: We had a lot
of redesigns this year.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
It was fun.
Yeah, OK.
We did a few.
In July, we to look at a
hypothetical cricket app.
So this is off the
back of-- Reto Meier
did an excellent episode
of "The App Clinic"
talking about his ideal sports
app and how you would build it.
But we then picked up
the ball off of him
and then talked about how we
might go around styling that.
And much in the vein of the
iterative design process,
we took this step-- this
application step by step.
So we looked at the information
density, and the typography,
and the visual
theming, and so on.
And built it up step
by step, talking
through why we were
making new changes
and how you change them.
And we went one
step further as well
and showed an example of how
you might redline such a design
to communicate all of
these design decisions
from a designer to a developer.
That was a fun episode.
ROMAN NURIK: Yep.
Very fun episode.
And I think that was it for
the designs that year, right?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, we run
out of steam in July it seems.
ROMAN NURIK: They take
quite a bit of time, right?
They're pretty time consuming.
They are very fun, but
very time consuming.
All right.
So the and more section.
We had a couple of
episodes that didn't really
fall into any of
those three themes
and we did want to talk about.
Nick, do you want
to jump into those?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, absolutely.
In May, just after
the conference itself,
we took some time talk about
what happens at Google I/O,
and in particular, to highlight
some of the sessions that
will be most
relevant to designers
working on Android applications.
So I put up a few slides here.
Three of my favorite
talks from Google I/O 2013
were this top row
of slides here.
So that's talking about
Android's design principles.
The second one was talking
about Alex Faaborg again--
That's a friend
of the show, shall
we say-- talking about how
cognitive science-- just
a fascinating talk, and
really one of those talks
that gets in your head
and sticks with you,
and you kind of keep
thinking about it
as you're working
on your design.
And the third one
I've highlighted
there is Rich and Jens
again who did similar
as we were just talking about
in the podcast [INAUDIBLE].
They kind of focus on the
process about going back
to first principles and thinking
about your information model,
and how you flesh it
out, and the process
of taking that and
turning it into use cases
then [INAUDIBLE] screen
design and so forth.
So those are some of
my favorite talks.
I also [INAUDIBLE]
highlight that we
had a wonderful
session-- call it
kind of Android
Design Action Live.
Although we had some very,
very amazing TAs or helpers
from the Android Design
Action community.
So shout out to you guys.
You're awesome.
Who came along and helped
us to run a session talking
about the kind of things
we talk about on the show.
About how to take an idea, and
flesh it out into a [INAUDIBLE]
model, and then
sketch, sketch, sketch,
to create interesting apps.
And that was just phenomenal.
We weren't quite sure
how it was going to work,
but I was blown away with
the passion and the ideas
that people brought
to that session.
That was really, really fun.
Unfortunately not a
recorded show at I/O,
but maybe someday we
can do it again one day.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, for sure.
We definitely have
to record an episode,
or record a session like that.
And we do have all
the materials online,
so if you actually want to
run through the same problem
that we ran through, the
same question, the same task
we ran through, that material
is all available online.
NICK BUTCHER: And the
last one I pulled out,
maybe it's more of a plug
because it was an Roman
and I session where we
took off our designer hats,
and put on our developer
hats, and instead
talked about how the
developers in the audience
can actually go about
creating all these things.
Rather than the
current principles
and the visual design,
about how you actually
go out implementing them, so
one for the developer audience.
ROMAN NURIK: OK.
NICK BUTCHER: And lastly, I
think as Roman alluded to,
somehow our breakout
success of the year,
by view count at least.
In October, we did
a show recapping
some of the more
interesting things in KitKat
for a design audience.
So some of the things that I've
highlighted here on this slide
talking about the changes
to the different immersive
or fullscreen modes
that you can use,
including the
translucent bar mode
so where you can actually
draw behind some of the system
Chrome.
And we talked about the
changes in branding,
about how KitKat has tried
to reduce the high contrast,
bringing attention to less
important things like touch
feedback.
Instead just trying to make
those more subtle allowing you
more space to use color
for expressing things which
are important or
require emphasis, rather
than the kind of highly jarring
responses to the gestures
and so on-- touches and so on.
Sorry.
We also covered some of the
newer documented patterns--
gestures, sorry-- which
have been codified, I guess,
in the design guidelines.
The things like the double
touch drag which you'll find
is a great gesture for
like single-handed zooming.
And you'll find it in things
like Chrome, and Maps,
and so forth.
That's a great pattern--
gesture to look at.
As well as, not really
a design feature,
but something that's
really worth being aware of
is the new ability
in KitKat to record,
to grab videos from the device.
This is a great way to get
your developer to prototype
something, and
record a video of it,
and you can pass it around
to get feedback from people.
It's a really handy tool
to have in your toolbox.
ROMAN NURIK: So that's it for
"Android Design in Action"
in 2013.
As you can see, we had quite a
long year-- 23 episodes was it?
We talked a lot about
some inspirational things.
We went on quite
a few long rants,
especially in that
Common UX Issues episode.
We did a bunch of
redesigns and mock ups.
And of course, we shared
some best practices,
some of the specifics on
how to use an action bar,
navigation drawer, and so on.
NICK BUTCHER: It's really
fun, actually stepping back
and looking at the
different things we did.
So do let us know in the
comments, or on Google+,
or Twitter, or whatever, which
kind of aspects you enjoy,
[INAUDIBLE] or what you want
to see more of in the future.
MIKE DENNY: Yeah, and
if there's something
that we haven't done on the
show before that you think
would be cool, definitely let
us know in the comments as well.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, we
have a bunch of ideas,
but we need even more ideas,
so definitely let us know.
So with that, see you in
2014-- god, 2014 sounds
like such a weird thing, but
it's like, it's tomorrow.
It's not really tomorrow.
It's just a few days away.
MIKE DENNY: The future is now.
ROMAN NURIK: The future is now.
All right, with that, as always,
I'm your host, Roman Nurik.
NICK BUTCHER: And bye
from me, Nick Butcher.
MIKE DENNY: And I'm Mike Denny.
See you.
ROMAN NURIK: See
you guys in 2014.